good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022 2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data sciences and through a grant
from the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences The Chosen theme for
this year is data science and the public
health consequences of the covid-19
pandemic where we will enjoy
presentations on Fridays at noon from
leading thinkers about the issues
promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of the covid-19
pandemic these in include but are not
limited to delayed Health checkups and
treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering
health effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus we are in the process of
receiving applications for our
2022-2023 application cycle and we
encourage Junior faculty members working
in areas such as infectious disease
epidemiology Public Health clinical
medicine population studies as well as
data science machine learning AI
statistics and other relevant domains to
consider applying we believe that this
will be an exciting and engaging program
we're characterizing the secondary
health effects of covid necessitates
unique quantitative approaches but also
new multi-disciplinary collaborations
participation participants selected for
our biomedical data science Innovation
lab program will Leverage The
presentations you're like the one you're
about to hear as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project
development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle
Washington
in June of 2023 today I am delighted to
welcome our speaker Dr Melody Greer from
the University of Arkansas for medical
Sciences she has a doctor of philosophy
in computer and information Sciences
from the University of Arkansas at
Little Rock she has a master's degree in
information quality and graduate
certificates in health science
Innovation and Entrepreneurship and in
applied statistics she has a number of
activities that she's involved with
namely participation in activities of
the American statistical Association and
the International Association for
information and data quality Dr Greer's
research interests involve data quality
and integration following years of work
in government and business both
independently and directing teams in the
in the collection maintenance and
integration of data Melody decided to
pursue her PhD and develop a deeper
appreciation of the underlying processes
at work which culminate in
well-integrated and high quality data
today she leads a team working to do
research search on data enhancement
quality and interoperability in the
healthcare field
in continuing with our 2022-2023
biomedical data science seminar series
theme Melody's lecture today is entitled
data enhancement and portability for
health care Melody will be discussing
the Paradox that while socioeconomic and
behavioral aspects of Our Lives
significantly impact our health there's
actually minimal social social
determinants of Health Data that gets
collected as part of the Health Care
system information of this type is
needed for Quality Health Care research
for patient care in particular because
it is associated with the full spectrum
of Health outcomes from acute to Chronic
disorders and in spite of the growing
interest including social determinants
of Health Data and Health Care process
there is a significant challenge
associated with its collection
management quality and portability and
Melody and her team work very carefully
in this area to provide answers for
addressing some of the challenges which
exist as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
YouTube and if you are watching on
YouTube thank you so much for joining us
also our specialist elected 2022-2023
biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged
to submit any questions they have for
Melody via their Zoom sessions I will
personally synthesize these questions
and ask them on your behalf in the last
10 minutes or so the lecture and with
all that said welcome Melody we are
super excited to hear from you and hear
what you have to tell us
hello everyone my name is Melody Greer
and I'm here to talk to you today about
data enhancement and portability in
healthcare
this work has been the result of a
collaboration with Dr City babatacharya
from the Arkansas State University
and we are working currently on
understanding the relationship between
colorectal cancer and the social
determinants of Health with this awesome
team you see here I want to shout out
and thank you for the NSF funding that
supports our work and the dart project
in Arkansas that is uh the recipient of
the NSF that has that supports what we
are doing currently
so today I'm going to talk to you about
two main ideas
the first one is that social and
behavioral data are important parts of
healthcare
and then the second one is we can get
this social and behavioral data without
making people answer survey questions no
one likes to answer survey questions
so
first let's talk about the types of data
that we have available to us at my
University and I'm sure many others but
we have some some unique features at our
University
first we have molecular and cellular
data at the arcgym project we also have
Imaging data from the cancer Imaging
archive they of course have clinical
data from our EHR that runs in the
hospital and we are the home of the data
coordinating and operations center for
the echo child pediatric
clinical trial Network and there we
collect data for each unique study that
that is run through these multiple
centers
foreign so we are focused on clinical
and research data right now
we have uh hopes to add in imaging and
molecular data as we move forward but as
a first step we're working with clinical
and research data so clinic by clinical
I mean electronic health records and
these are gathered manually as doctors
visit with patients or in an automated
fashion for patients who are perhaps in
the hospital for an extended period of
time and they're being monitored for
vital signs or blood oxygen
we're also interested in the electronic
data capture systems that are for used
for clinical trials these are flexible
flexible and customizable software
systems that are built
for each individual clinical trial and
they have to be tailored to the trial
itself and we're interested in
developing social determinants of Health
to be integrated into both of these
types of systems
so social determinants of Health
probably a lot of you know what those
are
but just so just so we cover anybody
that that has not been listening lately
the social determinants of help
according to the CDC are the conditions
and the places where people live they
learn they work they play and all of
these things affect the quality and of
your health and your life overall
what's surprising is what a large impact
the social determinants of Health have
they drive 80 percent of your health
what that means is only 20 of your
health is actually related to seeing a
physician the rest of it is all about
the rest of everything else that happens
to you
and what's stunning and and concerning
is that 40 of premature deaths result
from things that that are lifestyle
choices
it's hope we're hoping with our work
that we can help to address that
particular issue
this kind of data is clearly important
for Physicians to have
it helps them with risk prediction and
it also helps them with clinical
decision making
social determinants of Health are
associated with a with a wide range of
disease I've listed some of them here
there are many more
with this information
clinicians can connect patients with
services that are available to help them
with whatever social determinants they
might need and I'll take a second to
explain social determinants of Health
can be both positive and negative things
like exercise are positive and things
like maybe a stressful neighborhood or
or bad food choices would be negative
and so if there are negative
determinants of Health that a physician
is aware of these people could be
connected with things that that might
help them uh recover or improve from
that particular social determinant of
Health
this is the kind of data that they don't
have and the reason is is because it's
very difficult to collect
there's minimal social determinants of
Health Data collected right now and what
is collected is non-standard and it's
incomplete
efforts are underway to try and improve
this situation
um typically a clinician will talk with
a patient and maybe put some of this
information into the notes
um Community level data has also been
one of the ways that that people have
suggested to backfill this particular uh
these particular data elements but
surveys are the primary solution right
now
the problem with that is is that
providers are already overloaded and
this is another type of data entry
basically for them
and so
the data is is often non-standard and
complete for those reasons and then when
it comes to analysis the data that we're
provided is fragmented it comes from all
sorts of different sources so it's very
difficult to analyze and the patients
are not excited about it either because
they have to fill out multiple surveys
and they have to fill them out
repeatedly
so we're developing an automated process
to provide individual Level Health Care
data
that has a social context included
and I highlighted individual level here
for a reason
I talked about Community level data on
on the previous slide and what that
means is data that is at the ZIP code or
the census tract level
Community level data that is
used for social determinants of Health
for data elements
is
maybe less accurate well it's definitely
less accurate let's let's give you an
example so if you think about
an urban area maybe a particular zip
code
there are people that live in that zip
code who who might make a large income
and there are also people in that same
area who make a very little income
if you take the average of those two
groups and you use that as your data
point
to to think about the income of the of
the people that that are being treated
what you'll have is a number that
doesn't refer to anyone
in your sample at all
and so for that reason it's not and it's
not only about income it's about all of
the different variables if you take
these these types of ideas and you and
you take an average of them you're going
to miss people
no matter no matter what area they live
in and no matter what type of
methodology you use and so we are
focused on providing individual level
data points
as social determinants of health and we
want to deliver them in a standard way
that is complete
it is current and also this data must be
portable
in a way that that it can be integrated
into any uh Health System
so we've done some preliminary research
on this and we have a couple of of
papers out
and a couple in progress still on
covid-19 and social determinants of
Health
and what we did was we gathered everyone
in our EHR that had risk
features that would put them at high
risk for covet 19.
and we evaluated the ones that were
positive and those that were negative
against geographical considerations like
Urban or not and also health literacy
which we used a combination of Health
interest and Technology interest
s and also the area deprivation index
which is a community level variable
so we took all of these different
combination of variables and we looked
at patients who were
located in less urban areas and we found
that
patients were more likely to be covered
positive if they had a lower Health
interest and Technology interest
but that's not true wasn't true for our
Urban patients
what was most interesting about that
study
and and gives me a lot of Hope is the
fact that this was not uh related to
their socioeconomic status we were able
to actually separate out these two
individual social determinants of Health
which is a big problem with social
determinants of Health in general they
tend to be intertwined and so uh
untangling that is a challenge and we
were able to to make a to make a start
at untangling some of that data
also as as we did this work we also
discovered that that covered positivity
was associated with many of the things
that we expect like population density
age race household size but it wasn't
related to the area deprivation index so
this
is
a diagram of our process that we are
building it's it's a high level diagram
we start off with consumer level data
and we end with enhanced portable
clinical data that also has uh social
context
and I'll explain each of these
individual pieces as we go through the
next few slides
so we'll start out with commercial
consumer data
commercial data is
built by
compilers that that this is their
business
they gather data from transactions that
everyone makes
and they aggregate it together and then
they resell it to marketers
in order for the marketers to identify
people that might be interested in
particular types of products
this is primarily built from Financial
transactions
um
it is like discount cards also it credit
cards anytime you make a credit card
charge
um discount cards like you would use at
the grocery store phone apps when you
download anything on your phone all of
these things are transactions that that
get gathered up by commercial data
compilers
the only people that really escape the
the net of the commercial data compiler
is someone that is on a cash basis only
if you're only making cash transactions
or barter I suppose then those things
will not show up other than that um and
that's very few people now that you
would also have to not have a phone
would uh those would not those would fly
under our radar
so these commercial elements are mapped
over to social determinants of Health
using uh an ontology
now I'll also say that that there has
been I have heard some people concerned
about data privacy for individuals this
data is
has been given over by the people uh
themselves in exchange for
uh an app or a discount
and the data exists out there and it's
being used to to Market to get people to
buy things
it is our hope that we can use this data
to actually help people to bring it back
to to the people that that gave it up in
the first place to to whoever it was to
like I said to get a discount or to to
get an app on their phone and to to
provide that a service back to them
so I have a poll and I hope that
everyone will
have a look at this and answer these
questions I would like to know if I have
convinced anyone that social
determinants of health is it's okay for
your clinician to have that information
and I'll leave up this QR code for just
a minute
and give everyone a chance to respond
you know whether we whether we agree
with that or not I would I would love to
have feedback from anybody about about
the reasons why they would or would not
be comfortable with that and and what
might help to to
make them more comfortable
um these these data points are being
collected and used
in any case whether we take them and use
them to help people with health care or
not they're still being collected so
I'll take a peek and see
well we have one answer
so maybe I'll give everyone just another
minute or two I'll put the QR code back
up
no good
okay
I'm going out the survey will stay open
for uh a minute as we move through the
next few slides
so
the next component of our process is the
clinical data and this is what I was
talking about before in previous slides
the electronic Healthcare data or the
electronic data capture system data that
comes in from uh randomly controlled
files
these two sources are linked using
entity resolution
and that works by using non-unique
identifiers in a group to join two or
more data sets
and this makes our complete data set
we'll then have the the clinical data
plus the commercial data that is mapped
over to the social determinants of
Health but this data is also refreshed
all of it the clinical and the
commercial data must be refreshed on a
scheduled basis because as we all know
things change I decide to go on a
healthy diet or start a new exercise
program or quit smoking or
start drinking whatever whatever the
options might be your life changes as
you move through time and so we have to
make sure we capture that or the data is
inaccurate
the next step is a data quality
assessment
the data quality assessment includes uh
completeness which is making sure that
there's no missing elements and in our
case we have a novel imputation method
that Dr bhattacharya is building out
that we're very excited about
we're also going to measure accuracy
which this is uh like a surrogate for
accuracy there's many definitions but
but what we want to make sure is that
this data is mostly within our bounds of
expectation
we'll make sure that it's timely that
it's that it's fresh and current and so
we'll measure all of our refresh dates
for the different elements to see that
everyone all of the the patients that
are that are listed as well as each of
the features are refreshed on a regular
basis
we'll measure coverage and coverage is a
commercial
um
coverage is a different type of
measurement that is only used by social
determinants I'm sorry
by commercial data providers this is
an idea of
if all of the patients are listed
then not in a in a clinical set not
every one of them will be found in the
commercial set that is some of the
people whoever is uh living on a
primarily Cash basis may not show up in
the commercial set and so this is the
idea of coverage we'll also measure
relevance which is the perceived value
of the data uh
by people asking to use it so we want to
build a data set that is of course
useful
um we also want to measure Decay that is
the rate of change of data how how
quickly does it fall off and switch to
something else
and at the end we are left with enhanced
clinical data that is the data that the
clinical data plus the commercial data
mapped over to the social determinants
of health and importantly it's in a
portable format
and we have tested out this process
in a study recently
where we built out the enrichment
process and the integrated all of this
Dynamic social determinants of health
and did it on a repeatable basis to see
that we could that we could move through
all of that process we did the mapping
we haven't completed the ontology work
but we did mapping to the uh healthy
people 2030
elements and we demonstrated that this
is a viable source of social
determinants of Health at the again
individual level
so I have another poll I am at the poll
that we just did
ask if you were comfortable with having
social determinants of Health used by
your physician this one is asking you
in what way if if
those these elements your social
determinants of Health were gathered up
and it was determined that you were at
risk
I'm guessing that you'd want to know how
would you like to find out
I'll put the QR code back up the survey
would still be live if you were doing it
through your phone though and it should
switch over to this one rank how you
would like to be informed of this
particular problem
that that could affect your your
well-being and your health outcomes
I'll put that back
if you just refresh your
your phone browser it will show up and
then you pick whichever one you think is
interesting
and you can move it with the arrows
beside
and then you hit submit
yeah and this is not a surprise many
people would like to hear this from
their doctor
and so that I when we provide this
information through the EHR doctors will
have it
um but it's also going to be available
to researchers and and we're hoping that
there's also other mechanisms where
people can be uh
informed warned that that they're at
risk and here's why
okay
now we're down to portability
and interoperability has been a big
problem in healthcare
the definition of interoperability is is
Health Data that that flows between
different providers without any any
difficulties
when this works well it prevents
inconsistent information on patient
health records it minimizes unnecessary
medical procedures you've heard of
people getting multiple of getting the
same procedure more than once because
they've the health records are not
shared
it helps clinicians to collaborate and
and build integrated treatment plans for
their patients
because they don't always have time to
or even know that they need to connect
with other providers that these patients
are seeing and so this is a way of
keeping the the clinicians involved in
patients care process
and so how are we going to do that we're
going to use fire
best Healthcare interoperability
resources
is a data standard
it
defines how Healthcare information can
be uh exchanged with different Health
Care Systems as defined by healthit.gov
it has wide Acceptance in Industry with
most of the uh EHR vendors epic
concerner and and others it also has
buy-in from uh our big software
companies apple and Microsoft and Google
it's based in already existing web
standards which makes it makes it easier
for us to move forward in that direction
because there's already people with
these skill sets things like XML and
Json Etc
um and it's also human readable
but that's not all it also has a social
determinants of health component
and this evolved
fairly recently but it started out
because in 2009 the high-tech act
required that patient data be in a
standardized format so to support
interoperability
um initiatives then started to collect
Social determinants of Health in 2017
for example the centers for Medicaid and
Medicare
um started to require providers assess
the patient's social risks
and so in 2018 the gravity project was
started and it is built from a group of
stakeholders that want to build out a
set of social determinants of Health
Data elements that can be used for
interoperability between all providers
and this is that just to make sure this
is the portable format that our data
will finally end up in
currently in our NSF work we are working
with about 200 000
rows of patient data we are in the
process of working on the ontology and
the fire conversion section of this
since we have already tested out all of
the rest of it and in parallel we're
working to apply our methodology to a
colorectal cancer screening and rape
study that was with the team that I
showed at the very beginning
[Music]
the outcome of all of this work is going
to be
an expectation of patient social context
being included with Healthcare data
this is going to support clinical care
as we discussed at risk estimation and
helping clinicians to connect patients
with services
it's going to support Research into
social determinants of Health to help to
untangle some of these issues that we
are we we know are there and we don't
know which is the primary problem if we
can become aware of the various aspects
of social determinants of Health then we
stand a chance to actually pinpoint the
problem areas and make make improvements
or make Corrections
this is also helpful for operational
reasons it helps to reduce procedures
which of course saves expenditures and
reduces costs and finally from the
public health perspective it supports
prevention and control of chronic
disease
so this is my presentation I've got my
email here on the bottom I would love to
hear from anyone who uh has thoughts on
this and
um I'm hoping that that we have lots of
questions and discussion
um I'm going to put up a feedback survey
I hope that that you guys would be
willing to to provide me some feedback
so we can make everybody uh
interested in and and get lots of
feedback to uh improve our work
Melody thank you so much that sounds
like a fascinating project and I can see
multiple points of intersection where
people interested in in data science
um might be able to to plug in
um from your perspective what do you
think some of the uh what some of those
places might be
well so
we have of course that fire and ontology
are very the very technical aspects we
have clinicians interested in our work
from the perspective of
their particular area of focus
um we also have people that are that are
interested in data quality from the
perspective of how can we do the data
quality assessment this is going to be I
mean as we move forward right now it's
only 200 000 rows and but that's
just the beginning I can I can foresee
this at a point where we have
many many many more uh rows of data as
as much as the commercial data compilers
can provide so I think that that no
matter what even even honestly even
operational folks will will have an
interest because this this work pretty
much runs the Gambit and because the
government has an interest in uh
rewarding uh the collection and use of
social determinants of Health I think
that that I honestly I can't think of
anybody that couldn't find a way to plug
into this this type of uh project I'm
curious about some of the the how one
defines some of the social determinants
of Health just from the perspective of
you mentioned uh several standards
organizations or rather just standards
that are being brought to bear here like
the fire standard you know I believe
there was a one or two others and I'm
just curious like who participates in
those committees to help determine what
social determinants have held one should
be looking at it
yeah it does and you know and that's
actually another really good way that
people can participate not specifically
with our work but with the with the
gravity project and there is if you if
you search online the gravity project
um is available for anyone to
participate in which is really really
nice um I am a member but I think that
that there are different levels of
participation I'm sure depending on your
time and and interest
um so yes you and me and anyone else uh
that is in academics or business or or
governmental functions can all have a
say in this and in the way these
elements are developed and and put out
for everyone to use can you tell us a
little bit more about the gravity
project I mean you you mentioned it in
your slide but uh are there how long has
it been going on and how big is it or
who are the prime Movers of the gravity
projects
I don't I am not uh that knowledgeable
about the gravity project as far as who
the prime movers are now I do know that
it was started in 2018 uh it's funded by
the Robert Woods Johnson Foundation I
believe
um but and and they have they have very
nice websites where you are able to go
in and look at the elements that are in
development and um and participate at
that level unfortunately I don't have uh
more information than that
okay that's that's fine
you don't need to speak for them um but
I was just kind of curious if there are
um you know opportunities for people
um who are you know thinking deeply
about ontologies and then what one can
do with them
um and especially thinking about people
who are from communities where social
determinants of Health
um might be you know they may be the
most uh what's the word I'm looking for
they're the ones who's the so the
measurement of social determinants of
Health are designed to address yes and
that they you know they would like to
have a voice in the description of what
those social determinants are how are
they measured uh how are they codified
and then what one can do with them or
not do with them and that is such such a
good point and that is actually part of
the the community outreach uh that that
needs to happen because honestly I I
wouldn't be surprised if a lot of our
audience here was aware of fire or
social determinants of health or even
the gravity project but honestly it's
not something that a lot of people
especially just regular people are are
aware of and I think that that is
actually a good case for for our work
because we would like to have some
community outreach to individuals so
that they know that they they even could
contribute right I feel like there's not
a lot of awareness out there I think it
was you made a very important
observation and comment
um earlier on in your presentation about
um people from kind of more rural
environments
um
who
um it may or may not have been there was
a differential between the people in a
rural environment versus an urban
environment
um and there was like it was like their
their um technology
technological I can't remember how you
said it was like whether or not they're
technologically savvy and one of the
things that occurred to me was that you
know they're probably very smart people
they just may not have access to the
internet that you might have if you're
in you know New York City versus you
know a rural portion of you know
Southwestern Arkansas for example you
know
and I'm just kind of thinking is it is
it is an availability thing there's just
not the service providers
um who are you know basically dragging
cables or Fiber Optic lines to those
communities so they have ready access
you know and and I have I've heard a lot
about this it's I there was a study and
I wish I could remember the name of it
but there was a study that said that
everyone even in the most impoverished
parts of the world everybody has a phone
now
um and and I don't I don't remember the
study so I can't really support that but
what I have personally seen is that that
is quite true for even our our most
non-urban communities in Arkansas which
is the better part of Arkansas
um you are correct they are they are
they don't have the kind of access that
we do in a city they're they're uh
their internet providers are not uh it's
just it's just not as good what is there
and and it's definitely limited but they
do almost all of them had cell phones
and so I think that that that is really
the path to reach people uh most
completely and and the fact that that
the compilers found these people had an
interest in technology and an interest
in health means that that they were they
were finding uh a mechanism to to
to look this information up or or they
wouldn't have have come up on the radar
like that
another thing that you had mentioned is
basically one of the drivers of your
study and you talked about it early on
was using commercially collected
consumer data and I have long thought
like why are we not doing a better job
of as you know Health people interested
in health care of tapping into that
Trove of information that would help us
to determine like basically what kind of
foods people are buying so that when we
see that they've got health concerns
we're like then having to go and ask
them as you point out asking them to
fill out some raft of you know forms
about stuff you know we would know or
rather we would at least know about
communities
um if we have to anonymize the data and
I I really like that concept and I'm
kind of curious if you could tell us a
little bit more about
how you get access to that data are
there any restrictions on it um you know
I presume it's there's a proprietaryness
to it through the providers I don't know
can you tell us a little bit more about
your experiences with it absolutely and
this is a subject that is near and dear
to my heart
um a lot of people feel like that this
you know this is evil they they have all
this data but but I think you're
absolutely right it's not it's not
inherently bad or good it's it's
something that we can take and we can
use to uh provide people what what they
need actually and so
commercial data is is
like you said is collected by these big
data vendors and and it is uh they run
the Gambit from very very large data
vendors to uh small small companies that
that collect smaller amounts of data and
even aggregate uh Community level
information and resell it
so
to get this information if you if you
want the community level information you
can go get it yourself for free
if you want the community level data uh
aggregated into groups where it's it's
you you don't have to go to the trouble
to to hook all those data sets together
yourself you can buy that for for Fairly
cheap
if you want data about individual people
from a commercial data compiler you have
to pay for it
and it is it is
I liken it to buying a car you can go
and buy a car that's a stripped down
model where you can just get just you
know the standard car with the standard
features or you can start adding bells
and whistles I want nice rims and a moon
roof and you know some sort of sound
system or whatever each of these
features that you add increases your
cost and so your cost is calculated
based on the variables that you choose
how many uh rows that you're that you're
looking to uh have appended and and what
sorts of variables there of course
premium variables and and then uh
cheaper variables and the commercial
data comes in
kind of two formats you can there's the
raw data that that we are interested in
that is just the information
brought directly uh that we that we
purchased directly and then there's also
proprietary variables that are specific
to the vendors and a lot of times these
are these are really interesting and
good variables they're modeled
um
we don't use them because they are uh
they're black box I don't I don't know
how that model was built so I can't
really uh speak to it that's not to say
it's not valuable and somebody couldn't
find a way to use it I think you
probably could but we to this point have
shied away from those and and stayed
with the with the specific raw variables
that the uh that the vendors can provide
but they're also very happy to uh to
talk about and to uh to to sell you the
proprietary variables that they have
model themselves now does that data come
to you sort of
pre-ontological
ontological slide if you will you know
basically in a in a format that's
already in an ontological framework or
do you then take that and kind of
re-ingest it and remap it into an
ontology that you're using we have to
map it onto the ontology it comes it
they make data for marketing and that's
what they sell so when you get it it
looks like you know
um do you have a puppy do you own a car
do you want to buy a boat do you
subscribe to magazines about motorcycles
or you know or all of the and and in
I've I've just popped off a few uh
elements that that would be on that list
but but it's an incredibly wide uh data
set that they can provide and I'm
talking in in the thousands of data
elements that that are available so
thousands of data elements per the you
know for every one of the 200 000 and
growing lists of people that you're
working with now so it's quite a sizable
data set are you have you seen or
discovered any
unusual relationships that seem to be
seem to pop out that uh perhaps you
didn't expect or that were surprising to
you
I was I was
um
stunned honestly when when we when we
did our first first stab at this and
discovered that socioeconomic status
could be teased away from from the idea
of Health interest and Technology
interest a lot of times we think
we think about people and we think oh
you know social social economic
socioeconomic status is very much tied
to your your uh interest in technology
your uh the things you like to read the
things that you care about
um your educational level we expect all
of these things to be tied together
and that little part of that study was
so exciting to me because first of all
it said no that's not true period it
doesn't matter and or at least in this
case I won't I won't try to generalize
too much but I definitely now want to
pursue that into a a broader area but
that's part of the core problem of the
social determinants of Health that we
have right now today the fact that that
we know they're positive and negative
aspects but we don't know
um it's a chicken and an egg problem
right we don't know which of these
things is primary
um and so we don't know how to fix it
and
it's encouraging to know that that you
can take socioeconomic status out of
that equation and then you can just go
and help somebody become technologically
literate become Health literate
and and you've helped to them to do that
without without having to to meddle in
every other social determinant of health
because that makes it feel like too big
of a problem right when you can take
these small bites that's how you eat an
elephant right little bites one bite at
a time and so if you can break this down
into these different uh components then
you can you have a much better chance of
actually helping people
do you see opportunities for people who
are doing
um like machine learning methodologies
um text mining
um natural language processing and like
medical electronic medical health
records people who are working in those
kind of areas could they dive into Data
like this and just go crazy
oh my gosh yes that is that is
I have students that are that are so
very interested because we are going to
have such a rich data set and such a
unique data set this really lends itself
to especially as we're talking about
such wide you know numbers of elements
that that you actually need to to think
about this from an AI perspective and
that's actually uh I can't I can't talk
to you a lot about our our novel
imputation method but that is uh part of
the work that we're doing just to build
the data set in the first place for the
people that that maybe for whatever
reason didn't get into the coverage we'd
like to see if we can uh expand our
understanding of of everyone and and
thereby use this information to to talk
about even people who the best case
scenario would be even to be able to to
look at people that were temporarily
homeless and such but um but yes this
this type of data will lend itself uh
extremely well to to what you're talking
about machine learning
um natural language processing
not currently
that may depend upon the data that that
we are able to integrate with now and
like I said at the beginning we have an
interest in integrating with not just
the the data that is that is what I
would call well-formed and easy to work
with right now the research data and the
EHR data but we want to uh integrate
with image data and molecular data which
not that they aren't they are harder for
for us to be able to integrate into our
work but these uh also provide rich
areas for study and uh and grow this
data set even even more I think it would
be just fascinating to have you know
some a group of data scientists I mean
it sounds like you already have a group
already who are working on this so I'm
hoping that I'm in the right Spirit here
that have data scientists go in there
basically mine this resource that you
are constructing here
um because you'd be able to identify
communities where like that data
literature technology literacy uh is you
know it could really be impactful
um you could also find places where you
know it wouldn't be necessary and so you
know you can direct resources
accordingly and I can imagine it you
know bubbling up to being you know
policy uh people in the policy space
really finding that helpful
um lawmakers and you know Civic leaders
would be able to utilize this kind of
information
um in some of their programs
that is absolutely Our Hope and and
actually that's that's part of the
reason we have the metrics to send the
way we do we have people and much like
you're saying the the data scientists
that are interested in doing the work on
the back end to build out data and to do
data curation and then you have this
next level of people like clinicians and
researchers who want to take and use
this data to find out what the problems
are and where they are and how they can
help that is part of our colorectal
cancer screening study we have students
that are doing
um geospatial work we have students that
are doing uh work to find out cancer
staging so so yes this is absolutely
true and I'm uh I'm excited about the
opportunity to expand this all the way
up to policy
we have our Arkansas Department of
Health we have a representative from
there that that is an epidemiologist as
well on our team
yeah I think that things like resources
like this become so important for things
like that one question I do have though
is how does your ontology how do you
decide to grow it like if you you
mentioned having say a thousand
different metrics that you're tracking
but what happens if you discover 10 more
and you decide oh we want to update the
ontology my experience has been when you
try to change an ontologies after a
while it becomes like concrete and you
just can't chisel into it and it's
they're very hard to expand once you get
them started is there a process that you
guys look to kind of evaluate and vet uh
you know possible changes to your
ontology so that you're not trying to
Chisel through concrete more times than
you need to does that make sense it it
absolutely makes sense and and you have
me at a disadvantage ontology is not my
area of expertise at all we have an
ontologist on our staff
um well that's story on our faculty
Matthias berhausen and and his student
is working with us on our ontology
development and so this is part of their
work they will be uh participating in
our project in that way and I I wouldn't
I I certainly don't have the level of
expertise I am I actually excited to see
how they will how they will proceed with
creating the ontology we started off
originally
um mapping mapping these Concepts across
uh in a very primitive fashion just as a
proof of concept and immediately knew
that we would need to uh do this in a
more scientific way and so I'm I am very
excited that they're interested and
cannot wait to see how that turns out is
there a going back to data scientist is
there a role for data scientists to help
determine what the best thing what's the
best dimensions are to grow in that
ontology so in contrast to say getting a
bunch of super smart people to sit in a
conference room and debate about what
ones you know what elements to add could
the data itself suggest areas where you
could add the ontology and grow it
we're suggesting that maybe
uh that's a that's an interesting
interesting idea I think
there's potential for that I think that
the social determinants of Health that
that will end up finally being part of
our portable data set will be uh in a
large part dictated by both the
governmental mandates the the healthy
people and also by the the selection set
that the gravity project sets out
however I will say that the gravity
project is open to uh
taking on variables and building them
out based on community input so I uh I
think that that these variables will be
um selected by multiple means I think
there'll be multiple inputs as is uh
probably the best way to say that and I
absolutely think there would be a role
for data science in that yeah I would
think that you'd want to have you know
kind of
multiple ends of the spectrum being one
end of the spectrum being say you know
Community Advocates right you know who
are suggesting you really need to be
measuring you know factor x about this
community because it's really important
to having machine learning methodologies
crawling through the data identifying
relationships and perhaps identifying
gaps where you could go in and collect a
variable that is going to help fill that
Gap and help you know make make a bridge
that perhaps needs to be included
um and so there could be there could be
enormous feedback loops between those
ends of that Spectrum as well so there's
lots of interesting things that could be
done I'm sure yeah and that is uh that's
why we're so excited I feel like there's
there's going to be just opportunities
Galore for for many different uh aspects
of this work and that is that is useful
for for uh people of different skill
sets and I think you're absolutely right
I I would be uh excited to see how how
that will turn out as well
Melody one finally a question here
um what sort of information what sort of
things has this resource really helped
to tell us about
those secondary health effects of
covid-19
um whether it's you know National or
whether it's regionally specific you
know within Arkansas or Arkansas as a
state
um or just you know a county within
Arkansas have you gotten any insights
into what some of those secondary health
effects uh how they might be modulated
by some of the um uh the social
determinants of Health
we have specifically focused on covid-19
uh because that was what our pilot study
data was was around and so yes we did we
did
um find out that the uh the area
deprivation index was not very helpful
for that that our
um the household measures were uh
helpful as well as uh individual level
measures
um
we are hoping that that as we apply this
to colorectal cancer in in a more
targeted way that we're going to be able
to uh understand why some people get
screening and why they don't uh
depending on where they are and um who
they are what what makes you interested
to get the uh get your screening as as
recommended we're hoping to understand
incidents and prevalence as well across
our state our work has been focused on
Arkansas to this point because that's
the data that we have access to but as
we grow this work we absolutely intend
to uh
go more broadly about it and we're
hoping to partner with institutions
across the United States in order to get
a more uh general idea and and
generalizable data
um since like I said we're right now
focused on our specific institution yeah
I was just you know kind of curious
whether or not
you might be able to detect uh a dip in
colorectal cancer screenings during the
pandemic right obviously people were
locked down they weren't leaving their
house uh because of you know the obvious
reasons and as a consequence the
colorectal screenings went down and now
we're seeing you know now that we're
sort of emerging from that time where we
were locked down now you're seeing a
greater incidence there's this now a
spike in colorectal cancel cancer uh
diagnoses because now people were not
getting the screenings that they needed
to get
yes yes I I think that that I think
there's uh opportunity for that I think
there's uh I think there's a lot of
opportunity around cancer in general and
specifically colorectal cancer once we
understand better the the social
determinants of health of our particular
populations and and start to try to
tease that apart
well Melody thank you so very much for
sharing your work with us and having a
wonderful discussion about uh the social
determinants of health and how they uh
you your project is seeking to kind of
capture those and then so to relate them
to things like colorectal cancer and
covid-19 and hopefully other things as
well
um what a fantastic resource thank you
for sharing it with us and thank you
everybody for for joining us uh we will
look forward to seeing you next week
thank you so much thank you bye-bye have
a good